[Music]
in today's money watch we are talking
about American soaring credit card debt
on top of Auto student and other
Consumer loans as well as mortgages of
course get this overall credit card debt
now approaching one trillion dollars
surpassing the pre-pandemic high so it's
an all-time high and the cost isn't only
financial almost half of people in a
recent survey say debt has a negative
effect on their mental health including
giving them feelings of stress of
depression anxiety loss of sleep as well
CBS News business analyst Joe
Schlessinger joins us now to help with
all of that and our money problems Joe
thank you very much for being here geez
a trillion dollars that is a lot how do
we get here well if you go back to
before the pandemic there was credit
card debt that was building up but then
amid the pandemic we were seeing people
not just pay down their debt but also
build up their savings according to the
Federal Reserve in sort of the first 18
20 months of the pandemic we saw
Americans save 2.3 trillion dollars more
than they would have without the
pandemic then you know what happens we
open up we have that surge of like I
want to spend money I want to feel
normal I want to buy something I want to
buy something right and that's okay
people did eat into their savings but
the problem is that as inflation started
to creep into our lives people plowed
through their savings especially lower
to Middle income Americans then all of a
sudden they're like wait the grocery
store costs more the gas pumps cost more
now I have to go into credit card debt
just to pay my bills it's something I
know from bitter experience is if you
don't pay the balance in full each month
you're hit with interest and that
interest goes up when interest rates go
up right yes if you look back just to
the beginning of 2022 before the FED
started raising interest rates average
credit card balances were the 14 15
percent they're now over 20 percent so
this is becoming a real big issue for
many Americans it's so awful to feel
that you're paying and still not making
any Headway yes yeah it feels so awful
it really does so debilitating so what
are your top three tips for people
trying to get out of this amazingly if
you talk to a lot of these companies
they will give you some reprieve so
you've got to call and ask hey can I get
a little break can I can you lower the
interest rate is there any way out this
is a huge matter of just asking yes it
actually works you can also consider the
balance transfer so people with decent
credit credit scores can go and say hey
I'm going to move this balance to
another card it's zero percent for 12
months or 15 months and it helps you get
a jump on it the only downside is if you
don't pay it back in that time you know
what's going to happen your rate's going
to pop right back up and I think the
third thing is to try to automate as
much as possible right just get an
amount of money every single month out
of your account to get ahead of that
those payments even if it's just 10 or
20 bucks a week it's good advice uh Jill
Schlesinger always great to have you I
know it's down
very good to have you thank you very
much